العد التنازلي لنذور حرب حقيقيه بات يلوح
في سماء اوكرانيا وهذه المره بسلاح جو
روسي لم تستخدمه موسكو بعد ويفوق سلاح
اوكرانيا بعشرات المرات تقول نيوزويك
الامريكيه
واشنطن ابدت قلقها بشان تغيير استراتيجيه
وامكانيه استخدام سلاحها الجوي لتغيير
موازين القوى على الارض قبيل هجوم كياف
المتوقع
وبوثيقه كشف عنها في فبراير حذر من ان
منظومه الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه التي تعود
اصلا الى الحقبه السوفيتيه ستنفذ بالكامل
لحلول نهايه الشهر الجاري ما يضع كياب تحت
تهديد مباشر فروسيا وهي ثاني اكبر ترسانه
عسكريه في العالم تمتلك نحو 900 طائره
مقاتله متعدده المهام
ابرزهايف وسخوي في اغتسابن صممت هذه
المقاتلات لتكون خارقه وقادره على
المناوره الفائقه والتخفي ما يجعل مهمه
اوكرانيا صعبه كونها لا تمتلك القدرات
لاعتراض اسلحه الجو الروسيه المتطوره
وتحديدا في مدنها الكبرى
هجوم المسيرات على الكرملين دفع بقادته
الى التهديد بالمواجهه العسكريه بسبب ما
اعتبروه انتهاكا لسياده روسيا وتهديدا
لامن قادتها في اشاره الى تصعيد عسكري
جديد محتمل مع واشنطن والغرب على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه محاسن حضاره العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات